hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
Aristotle not only discusses the nature
and the types and the origins of
friendships in Nicomachean ethics okay
he also describes how they break down
how friendships follow her and what the
causes of that are this is quite
important for understanding friendship
before we go into all this stuff on the
board I would like to say not only is
this a perennial issue that's faced by
everybody at one time or another through
their life well I think one of the most
important lessons involved in all of
this is that when we have a breakdown of
a friendship and we are upset by it and
you know make all sorts of accusations
and recriminations or get depressed or
anything like that a lot of the times
what's what's actually happening is the
revelation that the friendship was never
really on the basis that we took it to
be in the first place many of our
friendships aren't quite what we think
they are when they get put to the test
they may in fact break down so let's
talk about each of the types of
friendship and why breakdowns happen or
don't happen within the scope of those
friendships Aristotle says
with with people who are friends in
terms of virtue it's not really an issue
you know there could be tragic
circumstances that's not really all that
common moral dilemmas typically stem
from things having gone wrong before so
virtuous people typically a bit less
moral dilemmas that not a virtuous
people you know he talks about if we
want to consolidate it in one sentence
why the virtuous are not going to be you
know breaking up with each other the
friends rival each other in doing good
that is if there is any contention
between them it's about which one of
them not can claim the most good or say
that they did the most good it's about
which one can actually do the most good
which is something quite different
there's lots of people who are prone to
call attention to how much good they
have done when they really haven't done
that much the virtuous people are the
ones who are more interested in doing
good than I'm getting credit for for
doing good and so there's sort of a glue
that holds their relationship together
in that respect
pleasure Aristotle says you know this is
an issue friendships a pleasure or less
durable they they change when a person
no longer gets the pleasure out of the
relationship that they want now it could
be that one person is still getting
pleasure out of the relationship so they
don't want it to end and the other
person does want it to end because
they're no longer finding it Pleasant
lots of friendships of young people are
like this Aristotle says young people
are particularly prone to making friends
and then breaking them rather quickly
this is something that happens quite a
bit in the adolescence why don't we hang
out anymore because I don't enjoy
spending time with you and sometimes it
may drag on for a while before people
become aware of it but Aristotle says
look it doesn't make any sense to
complain about a friendship that is a
friendship a pleasure if you're not
getting pleasure out of it just end it
right that makes sense where he says
that a lot of the disputes and arguments
actually arise our in terms of
friendships of utility and it says why
well because people who are in
friendships of utility are in it not
just to use the other person but to get
something out of it right they're not
friends with the other person because
they love them in themselves for who
they are they're not friends of them
because that other person is just you
know fun they have around their Pleasant
day I'm around or they enjoy doing
activities together they're in it
because they're there they're you know
ultimately going to get something out of
it from the other person so the friends
associate for the purpose of deriving
benefits and each person wants more from
the relationship than they're actually
getting and they think that they're
getting less than they in fact deserve
so if both partners are viewing this
that's going to lead to some some
problems he says that here we go
the friendship whose motive is utility
is liable to give rise to two complaints
why they don't get what they what they
fully want out of the relationship it's
always possible to desire more to want
things better faster you know higher
quality then you're actually getting
from the person then to feel a sense of
disappointment in the process and the
other person is doing the exact same
thing so friendships of utility people
will still associated with each other
because they are getting some benefits
but then they will [ __ ] and moan about
how they're not getting exactly what
they want so here are some what goes
into a very interesting analysis here
distinguishing between legal and moral
that is no median ethic a friendships of
utility he says it appears that as
justices of two kinds one unwritten the
other defined by law so friendship based
on utility may be either moral or legal
so occasions for complaint chiefly occur
when the type of
in view of the conclusion of the
transaction is not the same as when the
relationship was formed we is that a
question about whether things are sort
of explicit and drawn-out and there's
some ground rules at the start which
that mean you know presumably we follow
but you know a lot of times people will
say hey you know those ground rules are
not applicable in this case or you need
to be a little bit more lenient with
what you're expecting for me or you're
now living up to the letter of our
agreement or the spirit of our agreement
and then you have implicit things where
people are you know assuming things of
the other person and they're you know
food as a friendship of virtue those
assumptions would probably be
well-founded or a friendship a pleasure
they would know whether they're getting
the pleasure of off of it or not right
but with utility was exchanging benefits
with each other you know when we when we
put things out there and we just sort of
assume that things are going to go a
certain way oftentimes that's not the
case and we get disappointed so
Aristotle will go on they'll say the
moral type for example is not based on
stated terms but the gift or other
service is given as to a friend you do
something for somebody else
although the giver expects to receive an
equivalent or greater return as though
it had not been free gift or but rather
alone and he ends the relationship at a
different spirit from that in which he
began begin it so he will complain so
people do things for each other hey I've
got some free tickets here you want to
go to the game you want to go to the
concert you want to go to the movie land
you know you're waiting for them hey
when are you gonna reciprocate or you
buy the first round of drinks and then
I've never been it where's cocktails
you're like why am I the only one you
know holding the bag here as we say and
then you know upset these are important
you know sort of you could say spoken or
explicit norms and then implicit norms
and when people stray
outside of those then people get upset
and that friendships break down
Aristotle says this can also happen even
with the legal ones he says there could
be a business matter of exchange on the
spot or a more liberal accommodation for
future payments right when you when you
start getting into well what is the
future payment going to take place
people start to give a little fast and
loose don't they
he also says that we want to try to you
know render services to other people who
have given it to us and do so willingly
and he says you walked out to make a man
one's friend if one is unwilling to
return his favors so if you make a
mistake at the beginning and accept the
service from the wrong person that as a
person who is not a friend and was not
acting disinterested Li you should
accordingly and the transaction is if
you'd accepted the service on the stated
terms so that's you know sort of a rule
further forth um there another thing
that he says that's quite interesting
has to do with unequal friendships
Aristotle says that in an unequal
friendship in different ways each person
in the friendship claims to deserve more
so the person who is bringing more to
the table Thanks hey I'm doing more why
shouldn't I be receiving more what's
what's wrong with this picture why am I
being taken advantage of why am i
engaging in sort of a charity case
whereas as we say where's the love right
now he's got a very interesting thing
that he notes for people who are on the
other side he says on the other hand the
needy or inferior person takes the
opposite view he maintains that it is
the part of a good friend to assist
those in need what is the use of being
friends with the good and the great if
one is going to get nothing out of it so
in a certain way the the inferior person
is also claiming to deserve more than
they're getting there sometimes they'll
even frame it I'm giving you the
opportunity to show what a great guy
all right and so that that's not really
going to be that appealing Arizona also
says something in book nine that is
really central to this and I think ties
all of these things together he says
that disputes in friendships arise when
a person does not get with the zyre but
instead gets something else and why is
this a problem Arizona says to get
something else is in many respects just
as bad as not to get anything at all
it's very frustrating when you do
something for somebody and you expect
you know reasonably something else in
return done out of gratitude done out of
reciprocity and instead they give you
something else that you can't really use
or that you know perhaps they would like
but you don't particularly like and
Aristotle's being stayed a discussion of
all these things who who is a person who
measures who is the person who
determines what the value of what's
given it it's the receiver now the giver
who decides
so the giver should have that in mind if
you want to maintain a friendship and
there's all different kinds of
friendships as we've seen here you
actually have to give people what it is
that they desire otherwise they're going
to complain they're going to get into
arguments with you or they're just
things say screw this I'm not going to
have this sort of friendship I don't
need this as we say I don't mean the
drama I don't need the headache
there's there's kind of a trade-off
there Aristotle thinks this is very
reasonable so we should try to get
friends if we're going to be friends
with them and we want to stay friends
with him we don't want the friendship to
break down we should try to figure out
what it is that they need actually
desire this is in fact part of what it
means to will or wish good to the other
people which is inherent to the very
definition of friendship according to
Aristotle if you're only wishing good to
your friend in terms of how your friend
resembles you and buying them
sorts of presence that you enjoy but
they don't enjoy you're a man friend and
you should probably expect the
relationship to break down so those are
all very important considerations in
thinking about how friendships do in
fact break down we can dissolve over
time even perhaps how we can avoid that
happening